la discipline tire ses origines d'une
légende en 1969 un mexicain fait
construire un petit terrain de tennis
faute d'espacé sur sa propriété
le paddle est ainsi née la pratique
réunit aujourd'hui 70 mille joueurs en
france
mélange de plusieurs sports de raquette
sa spécificité et la présence de
paroisse autour du terrain on peut y
faire rebondir la balle pendant un
échange
la particularité du padel c'était un
sport ludique et addictif qui est assez
facile d'accès puisqu'en fait la
raquette est assez assez courtes enfin
voilà proche de la main et micro
convivial parce que ça se joue sous six
mois 4 la communication est le socle de
ce sport qui se pratique par paire pour
ces deux joueurs professionnels de
l'équipe de france cela permet
d'exploiter au mieux les qualités de
chacun johan viennent du tennis et moi
je suis un joueur perd paddle donc je
pense que ça se combinant bien joey va
vite vers l'avant joue très fort et moi
je suis un peu plus avec les vitres on
veut plus avec les effets le travail de
celui qui ne joue pas ces deux d'annoncé
où sont les adversaires dont sera son
partenaire de donner les informations
pour mettre un meilleur boulot possible
c'est un travail invisible mais qui est
très important assure en action pour
établir une stratégie de jeu efficace il
est essentiel de connaître son
partenaire on a une idée de départ à
savoir ce qu'on fait après on va essayer
surtout se concentrer sur nos points
forts à l'un à l'autre savoir ce qu'on
sait déjà bien faire dans un premier
temps pour essayer de se sentir à l'aise
individuellement des particularités
après il faut que les particularités
s'emboîtent cette activité aussi intense
que ludique est de plus en plus présente
dans les yvelines
plusieurs clubs existent au port marly à
bois d'arcy opecst ou encore à bail